it's been more than 36 hours and the
rescue teams are still
hard at work desperately clearing debris
in the hope of finding survivors
on sunday morning a part of the nanda
devi glacier
india's second high speed broke away
[Music]
debris and a huge wave crashing down on
the river below
[Music]
the force of the water so strong it
broke two dams and destroyed
everything in its path
it happened quickly leaving very little
time
for people to escape the collapse caused
two hydropower plants
to be flooded trapping more than 170
workers underground
at least 20 bodies have been recovered
but with hundreds still missing
the expectation is that the death toll
will rise
an investigation is continuing into what
caused the glacial burst
but recent studies have warned that
himalayan glaciers
have been melting twice as fast since
the start of the century
due to climate change environmentalists
have warned that this part of the
himalayan range in uttarakhand
is ecologically sensitive they want a
review of all power projects and other
big constructions
that is going on in this region with
climate change we are having more
moist snow now and as you know moist
snow
have more tendency for snow avalanche
and also because this area
received some significant snow during
first week of
early first week of february and that
might have
melted and it perhaps entered in these
small glaciers which has which had some
cracks in it
for now the rescue efforts continue the
hopes of finding survivors
fading fast neville lazarus sky news
in joshimat uttarakhand